بالفعل وواضح بان هنالك قصف مدفعي على
الاقل يطال المناطق الجنوبيه والضواحي
الغربيه الجنوبيه ايضا من مدينه غزه من
الصعب رصد هذه الضربات المدفعيه بسبب سوء
الاحوال الجويه والامطار في منطقه الغلاف
وفوق مدينه غزه لكن واضح بان هنالك قصف
مدفعي متتالي هنالك سماع لاصوات انفجارات
متتاليه في ال المناطق الجنوبيه تحديدا
لمدينه غزه وكذلك المناطق القريبه من ساحل
المتوسط نشير الى ان الجيش الاسرائيلي ما
زال في يقول في بياناته اليوميه بان
عملياته العسكريه مستمره في المناطق
الشماليه والوسطى هذه العمليات التي
تقودها الفرقه
162 وتواصل عملياتها العسكريه المركزه
وفقا لمعلومات استخباراتيه تصل الى الجيش
الاسرائيلي وواضح بان العمليات ونسق
العمليات في المناطق الشماليه اختلف كليا
عما كان عليه في الاسابيع والشهور الماضيه
حيث اصبح مركزا اكثر وضمن مده زمنيه محدده
وضمن اهداف بعينها تحددها الاستخبارات
العسكريه او يحددها جهاز الامن الداخلي
المعروف بالشباك لذلك نحن نرى بان هذه
العمليات وان كانت عدتها قد خفت مقارنه مع
الاسابيع الماضيه لكنها لم تتوقف على
الاطلاق وهي احيانا تكون شديده الوطاه من
حيث استخدام المدفعيه الاسرائيليه كاسنا
للقوات البريه وكذلك سلاح البحريه التي
يقدم اسنادا بحريا وسلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
من الواضح بان القصف ما زال متواصلا على
مدينه غزه المدينه تتعرض في الايام
الماضيه حقيقه
الى ضربات جويه عنيفه ومتواصله كانت
بالامس مركزه تحديدا عند الاطراف الجنوبيه
والجنوبيه الغربيه للمدينه وبعض هذه
الضربات الجويه كانت ايضا مركزه قريبا من
السياج الامني حيث تتعمد اسرائيل تدمير
المنازل السكنيه من اجل انشاء هذه المنطقه
العازله التي تتحدث عنها او العمق الامني
والاستراتيجي لبلدات غلاف غزه دا عن ذلك
نحن نعرف بان
الجيش الاسرائيلي من خلال خمسه الويه ما
زال يعمل تحت امره الفرقه 98 في المنطقه
الجنوبيه لقطاع غزه تحديدا في منطقه خان
يونس بعض التقارير العسكريه الاسرائيليه
تشير الى ان العمليه العسكريه بزخم الذي
نراه في الايام الاخيره قد تخف حده ووطئ
في قادم الايام هنالك من يقول بانه خلال
اسبوع واحد ربما تنهي القوات الاسرائيليه
عملياتها الكبيره في منطقه خانيونس او في
مدينه خانيونس حيث تقول بان الجيش
الاسرائيلي سوف يحكم سيطرته بالكامل على
هذه المدينه هذا وفق التقديرات لكن هذا لا
يعني بان العمليات العسكريه هناك سوف
تتوقف كما هو الحال هنا في المناطق
الشماليه لكن ما يختلف في المناطق
الجنوبيه هو ان العمليات ما زالت مركزه
وما زالت تعمل فيها على الاقل خمسه الويه
تحت امره الفرقه
98 وواضح بان العمليات العسكريه في منطقه
خانيونس لا تسير فقط فوق الارض اما انما
تحتها ايضا في اشاره من جانب الجيش
الاسرائيلي الى انه يعمل بكثافه من اجل
الكشف عن الانفاق الهجوميه التي يقول
بانها موجوده على نحو كبير في منطقه
خانيونس الجيش الاسرائيلي مازال يتحدث
ايضا عن عمليات في اقصى المناطق الشماليه
لقطاع غزه تحديدا في منطقه بيت حنون حيث
قال في تقريره الصباحي بانه استهدف خليه
كانت تحاول اعاده تاهيل مراصد الاستطلاع
والاستخبارات التابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
من غلا في غزه مراسل الجزيره الياس كرام
شكرا جزيلا لك